in a way to me this is sort of what uh
the producing art is about you know
you sit well like for instance these two
books that i'm talking about here gates
of fire and tides of war at some point
i uh it's a long story but
um i had to come up with an idea for a
book and so i brought
gates of fire which was about ancient
greece and next thing i knew i had done
five books about ancient greece i had
never in my life
thought about that wow i had no it
wasn't like i was obsessed with it or
anything i didn't know anything about it
but something sort of pulled me into it
and kept me going
so i think in a way that's the
if you're painting or you're making a
film you're discovering
what you already know right
and it's it's like it was in you but you
didn't know it was in you
and you don't know it's in you until you
see it on the page or it's on a song or
something like that
and what's what's kind of weird to me
here i've i've written like whatever
five or six books about ancient greece
but yet i'm not remotely interested in
ancient rome i just don't give a [ __ ]
you know
so why is